الان من غلاف غزه مراسلنا الياس كرام اهلا
الياس اذا كالعاده نحب ان نتعرف منك على
اخر المستجدات من الجانب الاسرائيلي
تفضل نعم ربما نبدا بما اعلنه الجيش
الاسرائيلي ليلى قبل قليل وهو انه قام
بعمليه انزال جويه لقوات الفرقه 8 العامله
في منطقه خان يونس حيث انزل من الجو عتادا
عسكريا وسلاحا ووقودا وماء واغذيه لهذه
الفرقه تضمنت
16 طن من هذه المواد وهذه هي العمليه
الخامسه للانزال الجوي في عمر هذه الحرب
والتي انزل فيها الجيش الاسرائيلي عن طريق
الجو نحو 60 طنا من العتاد العسكري
والغذاء للجنود الاسرائيليين في مناطق
مختلفه من مناطق المعارك في قطاع غزه لكن
عمليه انزال جوي في مدينه خانيونس ومن
الجو هذا يعني بان القوات الاسرائيليه
ربما تكون محاصره ربما هنالك مشكله في
عمليه الامدادات البريه من جانب القوات
الاسرائيليه التي تاتي من جانب غلاف غزه
او ربما ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يريد ان يمنع
قنص هذه ال القافلات وهي تدخل هذا العتاد
العسكري من سلاح ومن ماء ومن غذاء للقوات
الاسرائيليه لكن واضح ان اضطرار اسرائيل
لانزال جوي في منطقه صغيره نسبيا هو هو
امر يدل على حجم المعارك وعلى خطوره
التنقل ربما في المناطق المفتوحه التي
تجري فيها عمليات القتال لان عمليات انزال
جوي عاده ما تتم في ارض المعركه عندما
نتحدث عن ميدان معركه يمتد على مسافات
بعيده او كيلومترات كبيره مثلا لو اخذنا
على سبيل المثال اوكرانيا والحرب مع روسيا
لكن هنا نتحدث عن بضعه كيلومترات تفصل
القوات الاسرائيليه المتمركزه في غلاف غزه
ومنطقه البحر وبالتالي هذا يدلل على ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي بالفعل يعاني من
مازق في الامدادات العسكريه ومازق في
الميدان تحديدا في منطقه خانيونس هذه هذا
من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى ليلى وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يوف جلنت كان اعلن قبل يومين
ان العمليات العسكريه الكبرى في شمال قطاع
غزه قد انتهت لكن ما نشاهده على ارض
الواقع بان المعارك هنا حقيقه مستمره صحيح
انها بوتيره اقل مما كانت عليه في
الاسابيع الاولى ربما للعمليه البريه لكن
هذا لا يعني بان الهدوء هو سيد الموقف على
ال الجبهه الشماليه لقطاع غزه بل على
العكس من ذلك هنالك قصف مدفعي وان كان
متقطع لكنه مستمر وهو يشتد حينا ويخف حينا
اخر وكذلك الغارات الجويه والطلعات الجويه
التي تكاد لا تتوقف فوق هذه المناطق
الشماليه الماليه شاهدنا بعض الغارات
الجويه التي استهدفت مناطقه في جباليا وفي
الضواحي الشماليه لمدينه غزه في الاحياء
الشرقيه للمدينه وكذلك المناطق الجنوبيه
لمدينه غزه تحديدا في منطقه جحر الديك كما
كانت هنالك بعض الغارات الجويه التي
استهدفت المخيمات الوسطى كالبري والمغازي
والنصيرات بالاضافه الى قصف مدفعيا على
هذه ال المناطق كما ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
كان اعلن هذا اليوم ان اللواء 646 قد تمكن
من الوصول الى منصه الصواريخ التي اطلقت
دفعه كبيره من الصواريخ باتجاه مدينه
نتيفوت صباح امس وقال بانه عثر في مكان
الاطلاق على ثلاث منصات صواريخ كل منصه
كانت تشمل على عشر فتوحات اطلاق وكانت
محشوه بالصواريخ المعده للاطلاق اي نحن
قلنا بان منذ بدايه هذه الحرب ليلى تعرضت
اسرائيل الى احد ال صاروخ اطلقت من كافه
جبهات القتال 9000 منها على الاقل ربما او
ما يزيد اطلقت فقط من جبهه قطاع غزه ولكن
ال 50 صاروخ التي اطلقت بالامس باتجاه
نتيفوت كان وقعها شديدا على وزراء الحكومه
الاسرائيليه وحتى على الاسرائيليين في
منطقه غلاف غزه على اعتبار ان هذه المنطقه
التي اطلقت منها الصواريخ عمليا كان انسحب
منها الجيش الاسرائيلي وتحديدا الفرقه 36
هنالك من قال بان في المنطقه التي يخليها
الجيش الاسرائيلي او ينسحب منها
عمليا تملئ هذا الفراغ حركه حماس شكرا
جزيلا لك على كل هذه المعلومات شكرا الياس
كرام من غلاف غزه